[Musique]
alors à sociologue c'est quelqu'un qui
étudie le monde social
avec une approche objective que ce soit
à partir de
nombre de cartes d'archivés d'entretien
d'observation c'est l'idée qu'on peut un
peu essayé de dire la vérité
d'une partie du monde social
avec des arguments des preuves
un souci un peu d'aller un peu plus loin
que ce qu'on sait déjà aussi d'accumuler
des connaissances
voilà ce qu'un sociologue je dirais que
c'est quelqu'un qui remet constamment en
question qui remet constamment en cause
les
le sens commun
voilà un sociologue y sociedad oui bien
sûr c'est une personne qui essaye de
comprendre la société donc à la fois
comment est ce que les individus entre
interagissent et comment est ce que la
société influence aussi les individus
voilà un sociologue c'est moi c'est
quelqu'un qui cherche à étudier un
phénomène social a étudié un quelque
chose qui se passe dans un espace
restreint et dont il considère que à la
fois la société un effet sur le
phénomène qui souhaite observer sur les
hypothèses qui le qu'il formule est à la
fois que les individus qui va prendre en
compte dans le cadre de ceux de sa
préoccupation est bien aussi produisent
quelque chose en retour dans dans cette
société là après autour du terme etc je
pense que la personne qui décide
d'investir et qui fait état de la
méthode qui l'utilisent avec ses
avantages évidemment pour mettre en
avant son travail mais aussi ses limites
à partir de là fait de la sociologie
qu'ils soient
enseignants chercheurs pour les
universités étudiants on est sociologue
en sang soo s'empare de cette question
de et à coeur de produire de la
sociologie donc j'ai commencé peut-être
institutionnellement contrairement par
exemple à nos collègues de psychologues
ya pas un métier de sociologue parce je
veux dire y'a pas un ordre des
sociologues que
d'ailleurs des conflits de frontières
pour savoir qui est sociologue est un
sociologue
très institutionnellement c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait des formations de
sociologie qui est information qui a été
sanctionnée par bas par des diplômes qui
ont prouvé qu il était chercheur ou
quelqu'un qui a produit la recherche en
sociologie dans le cours de sa formation
donc soit un master et puis plus souvent
un test et qui a fait la preuve je veux
dire par ses travaux de recherche ont
été évaluées par des pairs qu'ils
pouvaient produire de la connaissance
sociologique
après je veux dire il ou elle va être
amené bien exercer son activité de
sociologues dans différentes
institutions différents endroits à
différentes occasions et c'est une
sociologue ou un sociologue c'est
quelqu'un qui
rencontre du monde social et qui qui
rencontrent des inégalités qui vise à
permettre de déconstruire des croyances
des des visions du monde à permettre
tout ça enfin moi je sais pas quand je
travaille avec des étudiants
seine-saint-denis et
voilà le métier de sociologue ce n'est
pas non plus que faire de la recherche
c'est aussi transmettre transmettre des
savoirs sociologie qui permettent
justement de de mieux comprendre le
monde qui nous entoure puis aussi
d'arrêter de soi même
ils ont des clauses sociales ça voilà je
n'ai pas dit pour moi c'est rendent
écarter les explications naturalisant
thd et fataliser enfin voila je sais pas
qui est sociologue c'est s'est déplacé
le regard un peu c'est voir les choses
autrement mais qui m'a dit à moi ce que
j'aime bien
ça nous retourne quoi et à oui voilà une
autre façon de voir les choses est
possible et
où il ya plein de gens qui ont pas fait
d'études supérieures qui savent pas
nécessairement ce que c'est la
sociologie bon bah voilà comme on disait
tout à l'heure le sociologue c'est
toujours un peu parfois une bête de
foire à ckoi la sociologie à 7,6 colog
vous êtes journaliste ah non je suis
sociologue nord c'est assez marrant des
fois de voir les enquêtés en train de se
dépatouiller pour expliquer à d'autres
amis à eux dans le cadre d'une
discussion ce que c'est que la
sociologie il ya parfois y arrivent
mieux que nous info lue mais non way un
sociologue un sociologue c'est ça c'est
quelqu'un qui est curieux qui est quand
même ouvert ouvert à l'altérité ouvert
ouvert aux expériences des autres et qui
est prêt à les entendre pendant deux
heures à une table sans broncher quoi
quand bien même le gars est en train de
vous sortir le discours qui vous dégoûte
le plus de votre vie si vous voulez
c'est un peu tout c'est un peu tout
franchement le sociologue pour le coup
c'est aussi je pense que vous êtes au
courant des toutes les fronde contre la
sociologie au ministère l'islam mais
c'est aussi un être sincèrement c'est
aussi un ennemi politique le sociologue
et du sociologue qui viennent détricoter
un peu les rapports de pouvoir et ce qui
se passe concrètement
évidemment et pas bien vu il est pas
bien reçue dans les bureaux c'est un peu
ça aussi il faut le dire voilà voilà bon
ça on va en parler 4 heures
[Musique]